my boyfriend he lost his cousin about a
year ago and he was really really down I
couldn't even get him out of it but I
showed him your trash talk because he
used to do that as a hobby so I've been
showing him the trash talk videos and
he's been doing very very well with his
flipping stuff and he has passion he's
happy now and I want to thank you for
doing that for him thank you for saying
that yeah it's been very hard for us
because we're both doing something on
the side and we're both busy and before
you I couldn't get him out of that hole
thank you thank you thank you so much
again thank you guys all for sharing
these nice stories means the world to me